bien le bonjour bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo casse-tête le concept du
jour trois cadenas casse tête
alors tout de suite vous explique et
qu'elle n'a casse tête c'est à dire que
si je prends la clé je la mets dedans je
peux pas ouvrir la can n'a pas la
solution sinon c'est beaucoup trop
simple et je me suis dit pourquoi ne
tenterait pas un virus sur ces cadenas
casse-tête en gros celui ci a coûté le
saurons et ces difficultés un sur six
celui ci c'est le belloc parce que ça
c'est blog qu il y a il a coûté 130
euros et ses difficultés 4 5 sur 6 et
celui ci le dan loc
il a coûté 270 euros et cette difficulté
6 sur 6 j'ai une question
oui c'est sûr si chaque créateur fait
skip nom alors je veux que tu m'amènes à
castelli des difficultés dont deux sur
ton cul mais les créateurs font ce
qu'ils veulent en ouais y'a pas la
confrérie des casteurs qui dix sept mois
voire temps casse tête
j'ai réussi vite ses difficultés 8h02
pour l'idée c'est de se dire est ce que
le prix fait l'intérêt du casse tête
parce que sud assez constantin qui la
paix concernant y avait plein de castets
qui est très dur qu'on a réalisé sur la
chaîne des casse têtes en bois ses 9
euros mais c'est un sur dix donc j'ai un
peu peur quand on enfonce ans à
l'intérieur jour voit alors je me suis
dit on essaie de se les faire plus ce
sera long plus on en garde rappelant que
plus tard le lot has car si j'arrive pas
tous les faire parce qu'il ya un peu
trop de longueur on fera le dernier plus
tard mais du coup est-ce que je les fais
dans l'ordre logique et c'est là où tu
interviens vous pouvez dire dans les
commentaires si vous voulez que je fasse
dans l'ordre du plus dure au moins du
moins dure aux plus dures ou l inverse
ou en mélangeant dit le maintenant dans
les commentaires
loïc tu lis les commentaires tout de
suite mais tu me dis ce que je fais donc
ce tac tac tac mais si on met trop de
temps sur ces deux là c'est à dire que
je suis là on fera en solo ok ok bon on
commence avec celui de jean-claude
constantin on a quoi on a un petit chat
j'imagine c'est un petit chat mais
vraiment il a une tête
chalus
comme on peut le constater il s'est fait
mal il s'est fait mal
clairement on lui a coupé les pattes
avant ça dans mon imaginaire ce sont ses
pattes est un salut pas d'humour bon il
ya un trou ici il faut aller il faut
aller creuser quoi on va pas se mentir
on a compris que si c'est le palau 6 et
palau truc est ce qu'on peut y aller
dedans attend c'est que vous n'avez pas
de l'abîmé des salaires de rentrer tous
aller au bout au bout je sens quelque
chose c'est un peu 3 si je fais ça oh
j'ai gagné quelques centimètres mais
j'ai ouvert en fait à voilà voilà donc
ça par exemple c'est un casse-tête
rondement mené
ben si je pense que c'est tout monsieur
ont clairement il est donc c'est quoi
que j'ai fait avec ça oui d'accord je
pense que j'ai été là à l'intérieur en
fait j'étais là et qu'en forçant comme
ça un moment donné je te dis j'ai gagné
un petit peu j'ai dû lever un peu ce qui
est ce qui écarte en fait c'est un
écarteur ces sympathiques
effectivement en difficulté un sur six
mois j'aurais mis difficulté cadenas
avec une clé c'est vraiment on en était
là ok c'est qui tu as des noms tels
bâtiments dalo alors tant que vous
voulez que je fasse mon intermédiaire
moi j'étais j'avais envie de me chauffer
sur le danois kim est ok non mais
attends tu as lu les commentaires tally
des commentaires tu as lu les
commentaires
dix fois dans les commentaires si vous
voulez qu'on fasse une vidéo après sur
le danemark
sachant que le dialogue 6 sur 6 on est
bien sûr un bon 2 heures 3 heures de
tournage alors là j'ai des difficultés
c'est de me dire est ce que j'ai le
droit d'enlever la clé de sa wii en vrai
à partir du moment où je peux faire
quelque chose j'ai le droit de faire
donc celui ci s'était difficulté 4 5 sur
6 on va la commission denquête des casse
tête ils ont 10 4
non ça qu'après celui qui avait dit
castiglia dit vous avez triché je veux
qu'on recompte m'avoir je suis toujours
président de la commission du coup ils
ont dit bon on fait 4 5 3 une mouette
alors le bloc dans la salle est fermée
on voit rien de spécial c'est la marque
ici j'ai invasion il ya un petit trou et
ici on a donc cette clé là rien de
spécifique pas détachable comme ça et là
on a ça et sans surprise il se sent
trompé ce n'est pas la bonne clé loïc
ces tickets alors il ya un lien gros
ressort à l'intérieur c'est vraiment
sais pas je ne rentre pas assez je te
refuse je refuse la présence
c'est comme si la chaise elle détecte et
que ce n'était pas la bonne personne qui
allait faire le casse tête et que la up
tu as m'éjecter à l'aide d'un énorme
ressort qu'on a vu en post-production
que tu es incroyable match en fait comme
si du métal et que c'est un objet qu'on
connaît je sais pas quoi chercher
est ce que si je le tourne
est ce que j'entends des bruits
particulier
quand on est maire louis jean comptable
et au bon on a pas de système à
l'intérieur est ce que il ya un endroit
sur lequel on peut appuyer avec cette
clé là il y aller il ya les cinq points
de serrure on les voit légèrement en
contre haas dont un qui troue et il est
où le fils que j'ai envoyé cette phobie
sert en fait meilleure marque et nabob
nabob bob bob en verlan ça fait quoi
quoique se servir à quelque chose je
sais pas par où partir ce casse-tête
mcef quant à la recherche de possibles
la clé je laissais dans son sens naturel
mais à l'envers
elle ne fonctionne pas mais pas de
système comme ça si je prends la clé je
prends la clé de ce casse-tête malines
savent au four en fait j'avais acheté
les deux en même temps qu'est ce qu'on
peut voir l'intérieur
je vais essayer de regarder ce que ça
donne au niveau des goupilles les
groupies et tend vers le bas si vous
voyez pas comment le fn serveurs en fait
c'est un système de goupilles qui sont
séparés en deux et on va les enfoncer
plus ou moins pour que la séparation
entre les deux groupes i soit dans l'axé
mais un ressort en bas de la goupille
vous voyez tout ça sûrement beaucoup
plus clairement sur un schéma que loïc à
trouver donc je me dis pourquoi je ne
peux pas enfoncé ma clé et ainsi
atteindre les goupilles et ce que je
vois c'est que la deuxième groupe i est
fortement relevé le voit à l'intérieur
de la serveurs actuels et il ya ce petit
trou cayla donc je me dis peut-être je
pourrais avec un objet baisser la
boutique pour enfoncer un peu plus loin
la clé est ce qui permet je crois que ma
théorie est pas si mal en voyant c'est à
dire que là je peux atteindre la
première guppy je le sens la deuxième
loge devrait pouvoir passer je peux pas
mais si je la bce avait quelque chose
tac je pourrais y aller et après les
trois groupes i restantes je pense
qu'elles elles se font
c'est sans souci ça veut dire qu'il me
faut un autre objet mais c'est pas
possible non mais pourtant il n'y a pas
de fumée sans pneus lors des manifs en
général ce qui est en jeu je retombe
dans ce travers qu'on connaît bien tout
seul vous si vous connaissez ça quant à
un casse-tête un truc un peu difficile
que t'as pas encore trouvé la solution
tu utilises un truc que tu sais que
c'est pas ça mais qu'il faut quand même
que tu laissais pour te sentir mieux il
n'y a pas il n'y a pas un truc de cacher
dans le truc noir tu crois que j'ai le
droit de le soutien avéré un petit truc
long et dur loïc tapas à ou alors
peut-être y en a dans la serrure c'est
pas comme les castes et tambourins gpara
j'ai pas peur de l'abîmer la puce peur
d'abîmer la table eh ben c'est
intéressant il ya vraiment rien qui n'a
bougé
ou alors j'essaie de la prendre un peu
plus par au dessus tu peux tu peux faire
une accélération à loïc ça fait
longtemps à loïc accélérons ensemble
[Musique]
je sais que j'ai un petit peu violent
mais je sais pas ce que tu peux faire un
close up sur ce que je vois là ouais
c'est tout petit en fait la bordure de
la clé je vois un petit point blanc
argenté je me dis c'est elle se trouve
ça je peux le faire tomber tombe les
tongs leod ils vont être comblés tong
l'été et à prêcher de la farine et après
mon gars on a du bon pas cher combler et
je me dis si c'est une petite tige
c'est vraiment le même diamètre que le
petit trou qui halal mais comment je la
fais tomber dsk pas d'autres accrocs non
mais la clé à des allées fait d'une
seule et même pièce
du coup c'est ça en simple c est souvent
tu apprends je la fais rentrer
[Applaudissements]
molière ça sort pas du tout je suis sûr
à 99% que c'est ça vraiment c'est la
seule logique possible ou alors c'est
vraiment un attrape nigaud
est-ce que je suis un nigaud possible
non ça sort là je les fais rentrer mais
je te jure je suis sûr que c'est ça non
ça se résout comme ça la casse tête lui
qui t'ai déjà dit la touche de résolve
aïeux [ __ ] ça fait mal à un bon doit
samsun on ça peut être que ça loïc je ne
vois que ça et ça marche trop ma théorie
des pistons tu sais j'avais fait des
vidéos je ne sais pas si vous les avez
déjà fait des vidéos sur comment on
ouvre une serrure en fait avec des
objets s'appelle bullock picking ou du
cambriolage aussi et j'avais fait là
dessus et donc d expliquer le système
des pistons et c'est trop mon truc et
trop logique c'est forcément ça et et
moi je pense que ça devrait sortir et
que ckoi insectes au rsa sports andré
tout à l'heure il avait commencé un tout
petit peu sortir et je me demande si en
tapant dessus manière malencontreuse
malencontreuse j'ai pas fait rentrer un
peu trop c'est pas mal ça sort pas du
tout aux allées plus dedans je te jure
il ya un trou à la place c'est pas
possible
ou alors il s'est enfoncé dedans je
crois qu'il s'est enfoncé à l'intérieur
mais c'est bizarre parce que je tapais
dans ce sens-là versus j'ai enfoncé un
truc dans un champ et tu vois qui tu es
tu m'as piqué tarot je vous propose
maintenant j'ai deux mains libres que
loïc tape d'en profiter pour vous
abonner chaîne youtube tm est gratuit en
plus et surtout active et la cloche
comme ça vous verrez les possibilités ça
me rend ouf
non il n'y a pas donné mans il ya un nid
de mes vérités dont la vie n'est pas un
peu fade
moi ce que je propose on pense avec loïc
qu'on a perdu qu'il est tombé qu'il
était sûrement bloqué ça peut arriver un
kiki que c'était bloqué dans le trou et
que la théorie était bonne on pense que
c'est tombé ces paumés envoie du coup
est-ce que je peux compenser avec une
petite tige en métal à moi pour tester
ma théorie à temps non mais je demande
dans les commentaires est-ce que vous
m'autorisez à faire ça lis les
commentaires loïc pas la bonne réponse
moi j'ai regardé j'ai vu qu
effectivement n'y a plus de petites
plantes c'est tout à fait creux dedans
alors là où c'est fort c'est que je vais
utiliser du coup le sait pas comment on
appelle ça un porte-clés qu'il y assure
le casse-tête plus dur suivant donc là
je rentre à l'intérieur et je vois le
piston et j'appuie clairement sur le
piston par le petit trou qui avale là je
mets la clé clé qui passe le premier
pistons sans aucun effort j'appuie sur
le 2ème pistons j'ai c'est que la clé
prennent la place du coup du deuxième
pistons et j'ai bloqué la tige de métal
si ça peut pas être un hasard ok je vais
le faire comme ça à ce que j'en pense
pas assez sur le sens c'est que c'est
pas ses droits c'est un peu trop julien
encore mon truc t'as pas compris c'est
combien tu apprécies l'humour le nom wii
klaus le lot du compte instagram
loue.com loup
thiam et b dont nous compte instagram
sur le côté charles loïc car tu es
devenu un influenceur d'instagram par
contre face une bonne influence sur le
milieu de l'humour y est à piston bc clé
peut rentrer fier peut-elle tournée non
mes clés bien enfoncer pour un deux
trois quatre cinq pistes ont peut-être y
est peut-être feinte il ya que 4 pistons
à baisser j'ai retiré la clé d'un piston
s'il y avait un piège au bout et en
temps normal là
[Musique]
mais c'est le truc qui ne s'arrête
jamais en fait non mais tu sais pourquoi
c'est parce que je m'attendais à un clic
mais comme un cadenas normal qu tiens
donc
cast est rondement menée et casser trop
fermé mais par contre un peu dégoûté
parce qu'on a perdu du coup on a perdu
ce qu'il y avait à l'intérieur de ça et
c'est dommage mais on a plus récupéré
grâce au porte clés de dames note
il ya un petit boudin satisfait a pas
comprendre si la tige est tombé et s'ils
ont la peau mais où c'est la tige s'est
enfoncé à l'intérieur en tout cas j'ai
bien aimé faire le con paradis prendre
b2 bon il n'y avait pas photo entre le
petit chat à neuf balles difficulté
assure 6 et celui ci je croise était à
130 euros du culte et 4 5 sur 6 moi
j'aurais dit 4 sur 6 si je faisais
partie du comité des casse tête je pense
qu'on est déjà bien long sur cette vidéo
lots donc la prochaine vidéo casse-tête
en fait c'est pas directement la
prochaine mais une des prochaines vidéos
casse tête ça peut être le dan locke je
sais qu'il faut trois quatre heures pour
le résoudre
est ce que ça vous tente dites le dans
l'espace qui est un peu prévu à cet
effet comprennent l'homme l'espace
commentaire n'oubliez pas de cliquer la
vidéo si elle vous a plu pensez à vous
abonner à la chaîne c'est gratuit je
m'appelle toujours fabrique a acquis la
cloche pour ne pas rater les prochaines
vidéos ici je vous mets deux autres
vidéos je vous mets deux autres vidéos
casse-tête ces dégâts c'est ce que j'ai
fait il ya très longtemps peut-être vous
n'étiez pas encore abonnés à la chaîne
et peut-être vous ne les aviez pas vu
c'est le casse tête que j'ai fait en
les deux premiers de cette chaîne donc
je suis là la boîte de pandore et celui
ci une espèce d'animaux et bus à très
bientôt
ciao